[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
78e pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8
politique émission dorénavant
hebdomadaire consacrée aux campagnes des
élections départementales et régionales
les deux scrutins se tiendront les 20 et
27 juin d'ici là nous allons entendre
les candidats sur leurs programmes
revenir aussi sur leurs déplacements et
puis bien sûr vous expliquer le rôle de
ces deux assemblées
nous débutons aujourd'hui parlent
élections régionales la présidente
sortante valérie pécresse se présente
pour un nouveau mandat son premier
déplacement officiel de campagne s'est
déroulée dans le département des
yvelines son département
rappelons qu'elle est aussi élu au
conseil municipal de vélizy résumé de
cette visite avec astrid bergère et
grégory canal et premier déplacement de
campagne dans les yvelines pour valérie
pécresse dans le cadre des élections
régionales dimanche 2 mai la candidate
était à saint germain les sur le marché
elle est allée à la rencontre des
habitants et des commerçants
je vais évidemment aller partout mais
c'était évidemment très important pour
moi aussi d'être dans les yvelines
parce que je vais être accompagné d'une
équipe formidable d'yveline wa de tous
les territoires qui ressemblent ils bean
et je voulais vraiment venir les
mobilise
dès ce matin sur place elle a détaillé
les mesures de son programme
valérie pécresse compte mettre en place
un rer vélo aussi une aide de 6000 euros
sera proposé pour l'achat d'un véhicule
électrique en vue de la future zone de
faible émission à l'intérieur de l'a86
la candidate met aussi l'accent sur la
santé
nous allons faire une mutuelle régional
pour baisser les tarifs des mutuelles
notamment pour ceux qui n'ont pas de
mutuelle employeur et nous allons faire
aussi une garantie immobilière solidaire
pour aider tous ceux qui ont été malades
qui ont eu un cancer qui ont lieu qui
ont le vih la mucoviscidose de pouvoir
annuler leur surprime d'assurance pour
qu'ils puissent devenir propriétaire en
ile de france
enfin la candidate souhaite mettre un
bouclier tarifaires sur les longues
distances en transport si elles étaient
eu aucun de ces tickets ne devrait être
supérieur à 4 euros
pendant son déplacement elle était
accompagnée des sénateurs et du maire de
saint germain en laye en soutien à la
candidate c'est une candidate de
conviction c'est une candidate de
progrès sur tous et qui projette notre
territoire francilien bien au delà
voilà des quelques mois qui viennent et
c'est une candidate qui je crois à des
valeurs et à saint germain on est une
ville de valeur et c'est important pour
nous invité sur lci le soir de ses
déplacements elle a confirmé qu'elle
n'envisageait aucune alliance politique
ni au premier ni au second tour régional
toujours et le parti présidentiel qui
peine à se faire entendre sur un plan
national et notamment en ile-de-france à
peine 11% des suffrages pour laurent
saint martin prédisent les derniers
sondages pour le premier tour
c'est loin derrière valérie pécresse ou
encore jordan bardella pour le
rassemblement national
écoutez à ce sujet aurore bergé présente
sur la liste de laurent saint martin
dans les emails déjà en étant présent
sur le terrain en faisant connaître
notre candidature c'est la candidature
de la majorité présidentielle que celles
et ceux qui ont aussi envie de soutenir
le président de la république est de
démontrer que ce qu'on a fait dans la
gestion de la crise la capacité qu'on a
eu à protéger les français quoi qu'il en
coûte protéger l'emploi protéger nos
entreprises protéger nos enfants aussi
avec la continuité pédagogique et bien
c'est aussi ça qu'on doit pouvoir
déployer au niveau de la région qu'on
peut pas avoir en permanence une région
un état qui serait adversaire alors
qu'on doit jouer collectif pendant la
crise je crois que ça c'est le premier
message qui est attendu de nous et puis
aussi je crois que les français pour
l'instant ils sont pas vraiment dans les
élections peut pas se mentir c'est dans
deux mois c'est à la fois très court
pour nous mais c'est très loin pour eux
donc je crois plus on va entrer dans
cette campagne puis on va voir les
compétences qui sont celles de la région
et ilan et cesser d'avoir une région
forte et je crois plus ils
s'intéresseront à ce qu'on aura alors
dire aurore bergé est candidate pour les
régionales avec laurent saint martin sur
le département des yvelines qui espère
donc vous l'avez entendu inverser la
tendance elle figure en deuxième place
sur la liste juste derrière un autre
député yvelinois mais du modem celui ci
jean noël bat le point sur les autres
candidatures déclarées à ce jour en
dehors de la droite et de l'extrême
droite et du parti présidentiel
europe ecologie les verts est mobilisée
derrière julien bayou lors secrétaire
national présent dans l'hémicycle
régional en ile de france depuis mai
à gauche toujours la france insoumise a
fait le choix de l'alliance avec le
parti communiste derrière clémentine
autain quant à lutte ouvrière c'est
l'ancienne candidate à la présidentielle
nathalie arthaud qui s'est engagé dans
la campagne on les écoute interrogé par
nicolas kirillovitch pour radio
sensations
il couvrira donc présentera des listes
dans toutes les régions et donc en en
ile-de-france donc des listes lutte
ouvrière faire entendre le monde du
travail
parce que nous pensons lutte ouvrière
seul n'y a pas autant brillé alliance
ouvrière seul parce que nous pensons que
les travailleuses et les travailleurs
quand tu dis travailleuses travailleurs
je pense à tous ceux qui sont sans
emploi qui sont condamnés à la chômage
tous ceux qui galèrent de petits boulots
en petits boulots et bien nous pensons
que voilà ils ne doivent pas donner
leurs voix à des politiciens qui ne
raisonnent que du point de vue de la
bourgeoisie des riches et des grandes
entreprises de candia donc les couteaux
vous en mets ma gauche même temps ce
qu'on appelle la gauche de la gauche par
exemple la france insoumise pour prendre
un exemple qu'on doit souvent vous vous
répétez sur lequel on doit souvent vous
interrogez est ce que il faudrait pas
mieux par exemple qui est clémentine
autain à la tête de la région
ile-de-france que valérie pécresse ou
pour vous c'est pareil non c'est non il
faut qu'il lutte ouvrière je comprends
bien qu'il faut lutte ouvrière à tête de
la région mais il faut être conscient
que sans une pression des travailleurs
sans une mobilisation sans sens des
luttes collectives puissante massive on
arrachera rien
[Musique]
on laisse de côté les élections
régionales pour les élections
départementales les deux élections vont
donc se dérouler conjointement même si
le scrutin n'est pas le même nous ne
voterons pas pour une liste mais pour un
binôme et le parti majoritaire dans les
yvelines et rassemblés derrière la
bannière ensemble pour les yvelines il
présente 21 binôme dans le département
autant que le nombre de cantons toujours
derrière pierre bédier quelques nouveaux
noms ont été dévoilés pour venir épauler
les conseillers qui souhaitent
renouveler leur mandat parmi eux et
grégory gare et astier le maire de
maurepas il se présente sur le canton de
maurepas en duo avec alexandra rosetti
la mère de voisins-le-bretonneux sava
plaisir de m associer avec elle
alexandra organique et conseillère
départementale sortante s'est jamais
bien l'alliance de l'expérience c'est
inné du renouveau et j'ai souhaité
m'engager dans cette aventure parce que
j'estime que le mandat de conseiller
départemental c'est un peu l'extension
de celui de maire c'est du concret c'est
la proximité et on l'a vu dès le conseil
départemental agit pour les communes
pour les habitants on le voit tout de
suite
autre candidat pour la majorité sortante
catherine arenou la maire de chanteloup
les vignes sur le canton de conflans
sainte honorine et nicolas dainville sur
le canton de trappes il siégeait tous
les deux lors du mandat et qui s'achève
on les écoute je suis une fille de
droite donc il n'ya pas de doute ni dans
ma tête ni dans celle des autres après
bien évidemment selon les positions si
je ne suis pas dans un parti c'est que
selon les positions je me retrouve
quelques fois plus près du centre gauche
quelquefois plus près de la droite donc
je ne peux pas me retrouver dans un seul
parti
mais le spectre nouveaux prêts que nous
représentons un ep y par contre me va
très bien puisqu'elle toutes mes idées
sont à l'enjeu les retrouve
je veux à la fois la décentralisation
parce que si elle vraiment au niveau
local que les élus savent faire ils
savent faire parce qu'ils ont tous les
jours les pieds dans la boue et tous les
jougs les habitants leurs disciples et
donc et puis à laver puis à la fois
accompagné l'habitant qui est libre de
son entreprise est libre de sans savoir
faire ne pas lui mettre des bâtons dans
les roues mais aussi toujours se dire
que tout le monde n'a pas la même chance
au départ
alors pourquoi je me représente parce
que
on a des très beaux projets qui sont sur
les rails et qui nécessitent d'être
défendu encore à l'avenir je pense au
commissariat d'agglomération sur et long
cours je pense également au pont de la
ville dieu qui est un point noir de la
circulation aux heures de pointe qu'il
faut doubler protéger les accès piétons
et également les axes et les vélos c'est
vraiment important que nos citoyens se
mobilisent pour ces élections
sachant que les conditions sanitaires
seront vraiment respecter au maximum
dans l'ensemble des bureaux de vote
et pour ce scrutin départemental dans
les yvelines modem a fait le choix de
s'associer avec la droite avait que
pierre bédier ainsi trois candidats
issus de ses rangs se présente sous
l'étiquette ensemble pour les yvelines
sur les cantons de morainvilliers de
montigny le bretonneux ou encore du
chéné rocancourt avec richard ii le
pierre le maire du chesnay c'est sa
première candidature lui qui vient
d'être confirmée par le conseil d'état à
son poste de maire donc après le recours
de l'ancien maire philippe brillault
quelques autres noms de candidates de
candidats à vous donner avant de faire
un point plus complet la semaine
prochaine sur le canton de saint germain
en laye une candidature de droite sera
porté par christophe bmc brigitte à
l'aise bourges
christophe bentz qui lors des dernières
municipales dans cette même ville
portait les couleurs du parti
chrétien-démocrate et puis concernant à
la gauche plusieurs formations ont fait
des alliances sur certains cantons à
verneuil-sur-seine europe écologie parti
communiste parti socialiste seront
représentés par nathalie moskovski
conseillère municipale de vernouillet et
fabien lemoine conseiller municipal de
verneuil
enfin pour la république en marche
seulement est cinq binômes se présentent
sur donc 21 cantons à
bonnières-sur-seine à mantes-la-ville
montigny le bretonneux trappe ou encore
versailles on écoute le président du
mouvement dans le département le choix
les cantons a été fait sur deux
principalement de deux critères c'était
déjà une cohérence avec les choix que
nous avions fait l'an dernier aux
élections municipales
ou pour nous il n'y avait pas vraiment
de sens à se présenter en face de
candidats ou de mer qu'on avait a par
exemple soutenu l'an dernier c'est pas
toujours pas toujours de sens donc c'est
ça fait partie des critères et comme
vous l'expliqué aussi on a envie de
on avait envie de présenter des équipes
soit des équipes de deux le candidat qui
représente le territoire qui soit engagé
donc j'en ai dit on a fait forme de
dentelle pour choisir les meilleures
personnes le 7 8 politique revient
mercredi prochain pour une nouvelle
édition nouveaux points sur les
campagnes régionales et départementales
scrutin donc 20 et 27 juin
reportage interview à retrouver sur
notre site internet sur des pages
dédiées à très bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]